Okay.
There were some very definite,
uh,
qualities to good leaders will.
One is decisiveness.
If you have decision anxiety,
it kind of says that you don't have
confidence and people are frightened to
be led by somebody who doesn't have
confidence,
doesn't appear to know the direction
that the company is going.
And you know,
you always want to get in the trenches
with somebody who you think is going to
win the battle.
And so confidence and is very big part
of leadership being decisive.
I think having,
um,
a sense of compassion is also important
for leadership because you can order
somebody to come in on the weekends and
work over time,
but you can't make them come up with
their best ideas.
They have to do that because they care
about you and they want to please you
in.
And you're a leader that motivates that
kind of passion in them.
If you don't do that,
if you're just leading by being a
dictator or by fear,
um,
eventually it's going to come back to,
you know,
bite you where you don't want to be
better and you won't get the kind of
dedication that you are looking right.